[Music]
the antenna me of the moral view of the
world that is that there is a moral
consciousness and that there is none or
that the validation of Duty lies beyond
consciousness and conversely takes place
in it these contradictions were gathered
up in the idea in which the non moral
consciousness has moral validity it's
contingent knowing and willing are
assumed to have full weight and
Happiness is granted to it as an act of
grace moral self-consciousness did not
accept responsibility for this self
contradictory idea but shifted it on to
a being other than itself but this
placing outside of itself what it must
think of as necessary is as much a
contradiction as regards form as the
other was as regards content because
however what appear is contradictory
propositions which the moral
consciousness makes clumsy efforts first
to separate and then to reconcile are
intrinsically the same since pure duty
that is as pure knowing is nothing else
than the self of consciousness and the
self of consciousness is being and
actuality and similarly because what is
supposed to lie beyond actual
consciousness is nothing else than pure
thought and thus is in fact the self
because this is so self consciousness
for us or in itself retreats into itself
and is aware that that being is its own
self in which what is actual is at the
same time pure knowing and pure duty it
is itself in its contingency completely
valid in its own sight and knows its
immediate individuality to be pure
knowing and doing to be the true reality
and harmony
with paragraph 632 we are now entering
into another subsection of the
phenomenology of spirit and we have been
laboring for quite some time through the
longest big part of the book spirit and
spirit is itself divided into sub parts
and we have been lingering in this
morality part for quite some time as
well you'll remember that spirit had
these three different sections and each
one of them has quite a lot going on in
it now we're at the end or at the
beginning of a section but at the end of
spirit does that mean that we've
completely exhausted the shapes of
consciousness well not exactly because
Hegel is going to go into yet another
quite long section although nowhere near
as long as spirit which is religion and
he has been tracing out the development
of you could say world spirit but also
spirit in all of its subsidiary shapes
that are advancing the dialectic here
and there and we've seen quite a lot
going on in this previous parts of the
morality section with this moral view of
the world the more Alicia Val Tom
Shaolin right and moral consciousness we
just passed through a section called
assemblance or duplicity castellan where
all these different problems or if you
like contradictions and antinomies of
the moral consciousness appeared and now
we're bringing them to a kind of closed
and not and as I just said beginning
again at the start of a new subsection
and as usual things start off in quite a
good way it looks like there's a lot of
meant going forward we should make some
progress and so let's start with what
the text actually says here he tells us
the antinomy of the moral view of the
world the that there is moral
consciousness and that there is none or
we want to look at another way the
validation of Duty lies beyond
consciousness lies in something else and
conversely takes place in consciousness
these antinomy is really plural although
here he's talking about it in in the
singular of the moral view of the world
these are going to be transformed and
we've just been you know unpacking these
at great great lengths in the last two
sections so he tells us that these
contradictions were gathered up in the
idea in which the non moral
consciousness has moral validity
now the word idea there is actually
translating for Stella
so in the representation not in the
concept or thought per se but in a kind
of representation a kind of picture
thinking of how things are and this is a
good place since we're beginning
intersection just to remind ourselves of
a few key ideas of Hegel so eagle is a
great distrust er of what we might call
okay enough but ultimately deficient
forms of thought and at the bottom he
places mere feeling to who right totally
subjective liable to change from moment
to moment and then above that we get to
the realm of force gentleman right the
representations and these aren't bad
there's nothing absolutely wrong with
them
but we often get caught up with them and
treat them as if these throws and
depictions of things are precisely the
way things are and this is how we get
ourselves into trouble
and quat in impasses in thought that
then the dialectic has to move us past
above this is going to be what is
translated in miller as the notion but
more often called the concept the
because if right and the kind of thought
that involves grasping - things in their
totality in their relations and in the
dynamic relations between them that are
in the process of change but have a
certain sort of what Hegel likes to call
necessity but we might just call a
certain rhyme and reason - and this is
going to happen in this section of
course as usual but here we're talking
about a representation and the
representation or idea is what that he
says that the the the non moral
consciousness has moral validity it's
contingent knowing and willing are
assumed to have full weight and
Happiness is granted to it as an act of
grace we saw all of these themes being
discussed in the previous section so the
non moral consciousness somehow would be
moral and the moral consciousness would
be what a hypocrite or duplicitous or
lying to itself really we have three
different terms here once we move past
these ant enemies we have the non moral
consciousness we have the moral
consciousness and then we have some
being other than itself the itself being
the moral consciousness so Hegel goes
out and he says moral consciousness did
not accept responsibility didn't accept
responsibility in what way does that
make it non moral or does that make it
immoral not moral might just be sort of
a neutral right in moral would be the
defective moral consciousness and the
moral consciousness does not accept
responsibility for all of the stuff
that's going on here this self
contradictory idea but as Hegel says it
shifted it on to
being other than itself and we saw this
already in terms of the the holy will
the you know supreme law giver something
that was a beyond and you know that's
already here the validation of Duty
takes place beyond consciousness we're
beyond consciousness and
never-never-land know beyond in a being
in some sort of presumed postulated holy
will now the question we can ask
ourselves is are these really three or
should we think that these are two or
are they actually aspects of the one in
same consciousness sort of bifurcated
actually trifer cated against itself so
Hegel goes on he doesn't answer that
question but he does tell us that what's
happening here in terms of the antennae
mieze of the morals view of the world
right yeah they are a contradiction as
far as content goes he says that moral
self-consciousness placing outside of
itself what it must think it was
necessary is a contradiction as regards
form just as much as the other was as
regards content so he's playing here
with the form and content distinction
there's something in the action or the
comportment of moral consciousness and
making sense out of itself making sense
out what it means to be moral which is
carried out in its own reflexive
activity trying to be moral right so he
goes on and he says because what appear
is contradictory propositions which the
moral consciousness makes clumsy efforts
first to separate and then to reconcile
are intrinsically the same sentence pure
duty now here's kind of a stretch right
pure duty as pure knowing is nothing
else than the self of consciousness and
the self of consciousness is being zine
and actuality vir CLE tight now we
should pause there for a moment what is
Hagel saying here pure duty as pure
knowing he's saying pure duty is in fact
pure knowing and we saw something
similar to this come up did we not in
the previous section when we got to the
portion where we led into absolute
freedom right and Hagel is going to
signal that in the next paragraph so
just keep that in the back of your mind
right and he says pure duty is nothing
else than the self of consciousness now
that's worth dwelling in how is duty the
self of consciousness isn't Duty
something that we experience as imposed
outside of ourselves upon ourselves
somebody says you shall or you shall not
you have a requirement you have an
obligation you have a duty well we've
arrived at the point through the
development of consciousness where it's
not a purely extrinsic Authority
opposing from above but rather quite the
opposite it's not even just some sort of
inchoate intuitive feeling from within
oh I should do this or I should do that
right it's not simply following out
one's destiny or one's character
whatever we want to say in in those
terms instead it's what we as rational
beings have realized ought to be the
case
for ourselves and would be the case if
we weren't so screwed up most of the
time right we're the imperfect moral
consciousness that we talked so much
about in the previous section but we
can't get away from duty we can't get
away from morality it's haunting us you
might say so he says the self of
consciousness is it's being is being in
actuality and similarly because what is
supposed to lie beyond actual
consciousness is nothing else than pure
thought and
in fact the self.y is pure thought
itself who's doing the thinking right
when you say that the the being beyond
myself the holy will the Gris Supreme
lawgiver whatever it is that you're
attributing could be other things too
though the force of history you know the
verdict of history any of those sorts of
things where we postulate some sort of
transcendence and we say that's the
thing that matters and I am just a
miserable worm haven't we seen that
before
a couple times already right in the
dialectic when you're doing that that's
really your thought Hegel thinks that
you're not recognizing is your own
thought so now we're called upon to
recognize that we're the ones actually
driving the wagon here running the show
that's my own terms math not a ghost
arrows so he goes on and he says here we
go thus actually consciousness is in
fact itself because this is so self
consciousness for us or in itself
retreats into itself and it's aware that
being is its own self in which what is
actual is at the same time pure knowing
and pure duty what is veer click right
is pure knowing and pure Duty now notice
what else he says here
it is in its contingency completely
valid in its own sight in the past in
its contingency with something bad right
we want to be we don't want to be
contingent in relation to the eternal
there's the unhappy consciousness we
don't want to be contingent in relation
to the necessity of one or another
spiritual power whether it be the divine
law the human law state power wealth the
noble consciousness on and on and on we
don't want to be a pure contingency in
relation to the Enlightenment do we or
absolute freedom no we want to be the
universal we want to be the necessary
not the contingent yet here the
contingency is what is going to embody
morality so he says it is itself and its
contingency completely valid in its own
sight and knows its immediate
individuality to be pure knowing and
doing to be the true reality they got
via clear kite and Hegel uses the term
harmony here harmony and in German it's
just a cognate right it knows itself to
be that so there is a return to the
individual and that's us at this point
in the dialectic
this self of conscience spirit that is
directly aware of itself as absolute
truth and being is the third self we
have reached it as the outcome of the
third world of spirit and we shall
briefly compare it with the two
preceding selves the totality or
actuality which shows itself to be the
truth of the ethical world is the self
of the legal person its existence
consistent it's being acknowledged by
others just as this person is the self
that is devoid of substance so it is its
existence an abstract reality to the
person counts and that simply as a
person the self is the point immediately
at rest in the element of its being that
point is not separated off from its
universality and therefore the two are
not actively related to one another the
universal is in it without any
distinction and neither the content of
the self nor is the self filled by
itself the second self is the world of
culture which has attained its truth or
it is spirit that has recovered itself
from its divided 'no subselect freedom
in this self that first immediate unity
of individuality and universality is
sundered the universal which all the
same remains of purely spiritual entity
the state of being acknowledged or a
universal willing and knowing is object
and content of the self and its
Universal reality but it does not have
the form of an existence free from the
self in this self therefore it obtains
no filling and no positive content no
world moral self consciousness does
indeed let its universality go free so
that it becomes a nature of its own and
equally it holds fast to it within
itself as a superseded moment it is
however merely an insincere play of
alternating these two determinations it
is as conscience that it first has in
itself certainty a content for the
previously empty duty as also for the
right and the universal will that were
empty of content
and because this self-assurance is at
the same time an immediacy conscience
exists
here in paragraph 633 Hegel is
connecting what is going to be happening
in this section as the culmination of
the morality portion of spirit with what
went on in the other two parts of the
spirit portion of the work and it's
always nice when Hegel provides us you
know some sort of schematic summary and
lays out for us what the connections are
supposed to be between what we're doing
now and talking about now and what went
on before and that's nice for several
reasons one is it does in fact help us
figure out what what he's talking about
Hegel is not the most clear thinker and
every single point now a lot of that is
because of what his task is and what
he's attempting to get down on paper in
front of us which is living thought but
it's also you know nice in part because
it helps to exemplify something that
Hegel has been insisting on this entire
time the previous stuff still plays a
role right it still matters this is what
out able or selection actually involves
right it's not a just well you know
people have this imagination of thesis
antithesis synthesis and you know you
got your thesis and you start there and
then you have an opposition your
antithesis and then you have a synthesis
that takes like you know the best parts
of both and kind of combines them and
then throws the stuff away and says all
right now we move on from here that's
not really what Hegel's doing instead
things are supposed to be kept and
what's essential to them is supposed to
be incorporated and given new meaning
greater meaning within the larger
context that's going on and so we can
see what Hegel's doing here as a
culmination of the entire work of the
self something that that came about
early on in the work with the self
consciousness section you know
for example in talking about the first
world here that it's a world that
involves recognition on our canon as
something important well that was
important all the way back in the
self-consciousness section it remained
important in the reason port part of the
work much longer much larger and it
remains absolutely essential and the
spirit part of the work so let's see
what he has to say here he tells us that
this self of conscience spirit that is
directly aware of itself is absolute
truth and being as we saw in the
previous paragraph is the third self now
that's a nice striking statement the
third self great what is the third self
and what were the other ones conscience
is the third in a sequence what is the
first one here he talks about worlds and
self so he says we've reached it as the
outcome of a third world of spirit and
we shall briefly compare it with the two
preceding ones now we get the schematic
representation right but we don't want
to just look at these in order we want
to see well what does Hegel making of
the path that he is traversed before so
he tells us the totality or actuality
which shows itself to be the truth of
the ethical world what's the ethical
world that's what we started with in
spirit right this world of x' italy kite
where we know what our duties are we
know our place and yet as the you know
for example the Antigone showed us or
the entire Sophocles and the biood
series of plays shows us sometimes
duties can conflict with other duties
and sometimes our ethical grounding
isn't so absolute because it collides
with another ethical grounding that
appears to be just as absolute so he
goes on and he says the ethical world
winds up showing the truth of itself in
the self of what the legal person you'll
remember that was the culmination
of that section so he says here in
wonderful phrase its existence consists
in its being acknowledged by others the
German is a lot more direct your design
is honor cons I'm right those design and
both of them the being the being there
the existence is being recognized being
recognized by others what gives you your
dye your place is other people
recognizing that you belong in that
place or even perhaps in conflict
contesting that you belong in that place
rivalry can be a form of recognition at
times and the legal person is given some
sort of standing within their society
through a code of laws right but there's
a problem here he says just as this
person is the self that's devoid of
substance so its existence is an
abstract reality it's too abstract
this is the problem of legal personhood
a section by the way where he once again
brings up stoicism right and stoicism
Hegel associated with a sort of purely
formal conception of the self so he says
the person counts but that is simply as
a person the self is the point
immediately at rest in the element of
its being that point is not separated
off from its universality and therefore
the two are not actively related to each
other I am my legal persona and that's
all there is and that's all there can be
at that point that's why we moved on to
the second world the world of culture
right he says the second world self is
the world of culture which has attained
its truth or it is spirit that has
recovered from its divided Mis the world
of culture was in large part this
division between itself and it actually
led to a kind of insanity and your Tom
as we saw which then required a move
past that into the world of faith
and the accompanying world of pure
insight which led us to the
enlightenment which led us alternately
to absolute freedom and the terror
that's the part that we're talking about
here absolute freedom he says in that
this self that first immediate unity of
individuality and universality is
Thunder did it split aside right there's
a tie on the splitting that takes place
here he goes on and he says the
universal which all the same remains a
purely spiritual entity the state of
being acknowledged right so recognition
is also playing a role here in absolute
freedom the state of being acknowledged
or a universal willing and knowing the
problem here is that it becomes an
object and content for the self which is
good right the self needs to be able to
depict to itself
what is the universal and how it fits
into the universal or even is the
universal but he says it does not have
the form of an existence free from the
self
so in this self it obtains no filling no
at no positive content and here's a very
interesting thing to say to conclude to
talk about I mean he began this part by
saying not just well there's the self of
this the second self and then there's
the second world the second were the
second self is a world the world of
culture right and he concludes by saying
it doesn't have a world that's the real
problem now isn't it
so what is our third world the one
that's not yet quite finished at this
point the world of moral
self-consciousness which we've explored
quite a bit in the previous sections and
are now going to explore new shapes of
in this this new section on conscience
perhaps in conscience lies the key so he
says moral self consciousness does let
us university go free so it becomes a
nature of its own
it holds fast to it within itself as a
to
proceeded alcohol business moments but
he says it's merely an insincere play of
alternating these two determinations
we've seen this in sincerity both in the
section where it was labeled as such
right previous to this one decembe once
but also in the earlier section on the
moral self-consciousness so he says it
is as conscience that it first has
something new something something that
can change the way in which things are
being played out what is that he says it
has in itself certainty self gives his
height a content for the previously
empty duty
the problem with duty in the past in
this was that we couldn't quite pin it
down we have this general conception of
it that's great but then it's really
abstract and then we have specific
duties none of them actually measure up
to real duty we have all these other
problems of you know nature and
inclinations and happiness and all these
other things tied in together and it
seemed like we couldn't actually do duty
anyway it was like a weird sort of
paradox wasn't it now we actually have a
Content he says we have a content for
the previously empty duty and also for
the right and universal will that were
empty of content why do we have a
content for them because they're in me
they're in me the individual I know them
through my conscience so he says because
this self assurance is at the same time
an immediacy conscience exists
conscience has has a place in the world
has a place in its world and it's not
happening through recognition by others
at this point it's happening through a
assertion of the self of its own self
certainty
you